what does it take to write a great story
the power of of good yarns good
narratives to um
pull people in is is a incredible and i
think my sort of
amateur theory is that it's an
evolutionary
development that
if you're um
you know
a
cave person sitting around a fire
in the rift valley a million years ago
um
if you can tell the story
of how you escaped from the hyenas
um
or
how uncle bob you know didn't escape
from the
hyenas and if if the people listening to
you can take that in
and they can build that
scenario in their heads like a kind of
virtual reality and see
what you're describing
then you've just conferred an incredibly
important advantage on the people who've
heard that story
yeah right and so they know a bunch of
stuff now about how to stay alive that
they could not have learned
in any other way
i mean animals who don't have speech
though they might warn each other
they might make a sound that says
danger danger
but
as far as we know they can't
tell more complicated stories
so it's a part of us yeah
the the collective intelligence seems to
be one of the the key characteristics of
the of homo sapiens the ability to
share ideas and hold ideas together in
our minds and storytelling is the
fundamental aspect of that maybe even
language itself is more fundamental yeah
because
the language is required to do the
storytelling
or maybe they evolve together maybe they
co-evolve yeah
so i think that you've got to work with
that and i think
sometimes it seems like in kind of
literary
circles that
having a lot of plot is a little bit
frowned upon as it's pulpy or it's
exploitative but
um for me
i don't have any
compunctions whatsoever about that i
like stories that
are grabby and fun and exciting to read
and
once you've got one of those going once
you've got a good yarn going
that people will enjoy reading then
you're free to do whatever you want
in the frame of that story but if you
don't have that
um
then you got nothing
what about having like uh
would you do a technological scientific
rigor like to the the accuracy and as
much as possible
how does that add to the
to to bob telling the story or telling
the story about bob or on the campfire
well the main thing that it does is
present
little details that you might not have
come up with on your own
so if you're just sitting there freely
imagining things um
you uh
you
your your brain probably isn't going to
serve up the wealth of details and the
resulting complications and surprises
that real
that the real world
is constantly presenting us with and so
um in my case
if i'm trying to write a story about you
know some that involves some technology
like a rocket
or a orbital maneuvers or whatever then
delving into those details eventually is
going to turn up some weird unexpected
you know thing that
gives me material to work with but also
subliminally readers who see that
are gonna
be drawn in more
because they're going to uh
to to find that um oh i didn't see that
coming you know
you know it's got some of the complexity
and surprise value of the real world
yeah it does something um
alex garland director who did who wrote
directed ex machina
i think about ai movies
and the more care you take in making it
accurate
the more compelling the story becomes
smile
i'm not i'm not sure what that is
uh maybe because it becomes more real to
the people writing the story
maybe it just makes you a better writer
the key to any storytelling is getting
the the readers to suspend their
their disbelief and there's all kinds of
triggers and little tells that can break
that right um and once it's broken it's
really hard to get it back
uh
you know a lot of times that's the end
somebody will just close the book and
not
pick it up
you